often when someone makes an argument and
comes to a conclusion they don't always
come out and explicitly state all of
their premises some of the premises that
are needed to get us to the conclusion
are left out and assumed to be true
here's an example premise Barack Obama
served two terms as president conclusion
at the end of Obama's second term he was
not eligible for re-election in 2016 but
to get from that premise to this
conclusion we actually need another
premise which is that the law prohibits
presidents from serving more than two
terms because this premise wasn't
explicitly presented in the argument
this is what we would call a suppressed
premise or an implicit premise and
sometimes having suppressed premises is
okay and it's more common than you might
think it's fine to leave a premise
suppressed if it fits both of the
following two criteria if the premise is
universally accepted and if it's
knowledge that the person or people
you're speaking to already have in my
argument about Barack Obama it would be
okay to leave out the premise about
presidents being bound legally to two
terms if the person who I'm speaking to
already knows that this premise is true
but here's another argument premise we
want fewer people to die from drug
addiction conclusion the war on drugs
should continue the suppressed or
implicit premise here is that the war on
drugs reduces deaths caused by drug
addiction whether or not this premise is
true it's controversial and it cannot be
assumed that this premise is obvious to
the person listening to the argument and
that's why it's important for us to
recognize when premises may be implicit
in an argument when the argument is
presented if a controversial or
questionable premise is being implied
the person making the argument may have
a responsibility to justify that claim
as well implicit premises can create
fallacies just as easily as stated
premises this miniseries
is made possible in part by brilliant
brilliant
is an online learning community where
over five million users come together to
help each other improve their skills in
the domains of philosophy math and
science you can interact with curious
people you can solve hands-on real-world
problems developed by educators and
experts from all over the globe if
you're enjoying our critical thinking
mini series you'll love brilliance
immersive lessons on problem solving
logic multi-level thinking deductive
reasoning and tons more you can actually
build a connection with the subjects
you're learning by interacting with
other learners sign up for free by going
to brilliant org slash critical thinking
I've put a link in the description under
this video and the first 200 people who
visit brilliant org slash critical
thinking will get 20% off an annual
Premium Membership visit brilliant org
slash critical thinking